puede haber paz en Ucrania en un futuro
inmediato Esta es la hipótesis que surge
en medio de los avances de las fuerzas
ucranianas en el terreno pero para
Ucrania no a cualquier precio
cuando tienes la iniciativa en el campo
de batalla es un poco extraño recibir
propuestas como no podrás hacer todo por
los medios militares tienes que negociar
liderar las negociaciones cuando tienes
la iniciativa significa que Ucrania debe
capitular en este sentido el
internacionalista Jesús agreda argumentó
aspectos clave de la ofensiva y del
apoyo occidental en entrevista para
France 24 claro
al menos en el sur y superar al niño por
supuesto Ya de por sí mismo solamente
difícil lo que significa que este
impulso que Ucrania tiene en este
momento se puede frenar Pero por otro
lado efectivamente digamos es avanzada
depende muchísimo de del apoyo de
occidente lo que vemos es que hay una
presión muy significativa de ese
occidente esos aliados de Ucrania por
Buscar una salida negociada Rusia tiene
otra teoría sobre la posición
occidentales
ellos son muy conscientes de que este
proceso se ve obstaculizado por Ucrania
que prohíben las negociaciones con la
federación rusa a través de leyes y por
decretos de seneski pero cambiarás el
discurso de no negociar con Putin es
imposible para el profesor agreda Porque
la idea de Ucrania es tratar de
aprovechar toda la presión generada
sobre occidente para lograr sus
objetivos políticos entre ellos está la
recuperación de las fronteras
establecidas antes de la invasión lo que
hoy es inviable para Rusia que seguirá
exigiendo además la neutralidad de
Ucrania